so right here we have the number 46 we
have a 4 in the tens place so it
literally represents 4 tens and we see
them here 1 2 3 4 tens that's a 10
that's a 10 that's a 10 and that's a 10
each of these are 10 squares so
altogether we have 4 tens or 4d squares
in purple and then we have a six in the
ones place we have a six in the ones
place so we have six ones and we see
that right over here 1 2 3 4 5 6 so we
can write that 46 do the same colors 46
is equal to 4 tens 4 tens and six ones
or I could write plus 6 plus 6 ones now
let's do something interesting let's
subtract let's subtract 4 ones from the
46 so let's think about what it means to
take let's take 46 so we're going to
start with 46 just the number that we
have in front of us and we are going to
subtract 4 we are going to subtract 4
what is this going to be equal to how
many tens so it's going to be a certain
number of tens and it's going to be plus
a certain number of ones plus a certain
number of ones so I've left blanks right
over here so how many tens are we going
to have so 46 that's what we started
with we're subtracting 4 ones so we're
going to subtract one two three four
we're going to take away four ones so
how many tens do we have well we still
have four tens so let's write that that
let's write that down we still have four
tens but now how many ones do we have
well now we only have two ones we only
have two ones and so you see when you
had four tens and six ones and you
subtracted four ones well six ones minus
four ones is two ones and so we get 46
let me do that in the same color we get
forty I'm having issues here so this is
going to be this is going to be 46 minus
four is equal to four tens well that's
just a four in the tens place so write a
four in the tens place and then two ones
put a two in the ones place forty two
forty six minus four is 42 and you can
see that right there in the ones place
we just took four from this six